[Music]
human remains discovered at lake mead
five cases since may now one case closed
and a family can have a proper service
for their loved one that's right
skeletal remains found on may 7th are
those of 42 year old thomas earned of
las vegas he drowned in the summer of
2002 i spoke to his sister today she
shared with me what happened that day on
the lake
20 years after a deadly incident on lake
mead the family of thomas ernt is
speaking out his sister julie sharing
these pictures of the victim who lived
in las vegas for more than 20 years on
august 2nd 2002 ernt his two children
and two adults were boating and swimming
she says they all jumped in the water
but her brother never came back up
on may 7 kayakers discovered the
skeletal remains in caulville bay on the
north side of the lake police and park
officials determined the death was not
suspicious
julie tells me her niece and nephew
provided their dna to investigators and
there's a match
thomas ernt was a single dad his family
says he worked very hard as an airplane
mechanic for scenic airlines and had a
passion for muscle cars days after the
drowning the family held a memorial in
their hometown of cincinnati but hopeful
they say that investigators would find a
body
now the family says they are still in
shock about the discovery and a lot of
emotions have also resurfaced
thomas ernst's sister says the past 20
years have been painful for the entire
family but they are glad to finally have
some closure now we're told
his son also just took his engagement
pictures at lake mead because they
consider it a sacred place for the
family